I'm very dirty or should I say dirty to
clean my act up
hi guys there's great talent no now you
know your life is different now I am
talking my head to an angle so you can
see I have a ponytail and not just no
hair welcome to the world's favorite
summer game show
will my tart exist somewhere but for me
it's brand new there don't work I'm
gonna take three fabric ish items and
see if I can make them into a bikini
today's fabric ish our old pair of jeans
paper bag cut some old dog toy let's
jump right in and see hey kitty this is
the content you've come to the internet
for I am mercury trine kini is our jeans
that I think the jeans are most likely
to kini
but basically already the structure for
kini bottoms here so I'm just going to
cut a crotch area of these old jeans
into kini bottoms I broke my good
scissors this morning or have my badge
isn't so that's going to be the reason
this turns out that kini bottom here we
go what constitutes a kini and it's just
two separate pieces of similar fabrics
that are water tolerant maybe no I don't
want to cut the crotch kini bikini
because of crotches in clothes I don't
want to cut open the crop or to the wise
never cut open the crotch wish I had my
good scissors okay monkey need an kini a
genie maybe a genie what's good
Oh genie coming remember genie bottoms
yes they look like shorts okay I mean
genie these more come on my butthole
we're my crew Terfel hanging out and how
does this work
this is our jean teeny bottom now I need
a jean kini pop okay did not sink this
part through our whatsoever as a hot
glue gun and we're going to basically
just make some triangles cut open this
like okay
this did not really add what I'm trying
to do if you were going to cut out the
triangles here yes let me do a triangle
and then we want string up from the
triangle oh that oh my god haha yeah it
feels like it might be bad according to
this jean kini my boobs are very far
away because I my hot glue a little
piece in the middle
oh I'm just going to cut up some gene
pieces and glue them hot glue them on
make it feel super like Britney and
Justin circa 2000 jean denim moments oh
I'm so strong oh therapy whoo-hoo oh my
god it's gonna be Rustica
[Music]
okay wow what a genie genie is done
we're going to test this at the end
let's move on to our next keening inner
bag we lit Keaney hmm favorite bikini
bottom's neither huh this might work
take your bag at Keeney's we'll test
this our demo move on to our third
Keaney old dog toys this is the one I
have the lowest expectations for let's
try it it feels like I have the most
fabrics hmm this is going to be wildly
inappropriate
alright so sorry oh my god like I don't
like this at all stepping out we can
find the thing is symbolic or disgusting
about what's happening right now
sorry your service I'm getting straight
I know I didn't say string up artists
I'm getting screwed I'm using old
shoelaces I know I didn't say that
specifically the beginning but it's my
game my rules
observe adult respect in these sneakers
for some reason so that's how often I
use these sneakers so we are going to
you're going to be our Keaney top we're
going to hot glue you that's the cake
top right this is what we're gonna do or
shoelace you're going to be our key
bottom paint a custom home I guess that
or we already the whole in this toy
because my dog likes to rip out these
squeaky parts of all of her dog toys and
then just discard them completely I
think this could be a Keeney bottom
we've got to get something going between
these this is a fun dog toy I'm gonna go
nuts protective just been so sane up
until now now guys I think we have our
youth dog toy kini Baba that was the
moment of truth will our teenie geenie
let's find out I guess the grammar check
it's on the kinky Nia's can it get it
wet and withstand the wetness
I don't know cool I have a tub let's see
will icky icky knees
does not see me halfway kinis well there
you go you finished the premiere episode
of will at Keaney give me suggestions in
the comments down below on other fabric
ish items that I should figure out if I
can make a bikini out of if you like
this video give it a thumbs up and don't
forget to click subscribe to this
YouTube channel I make videos Monday
Wednesday and Friday sometimes sometimes
on different
sometimes not on those days it's a
Pandora's box
ooh will that kini I don't know do I
need a tray for my tips on here for the
book no I won't do that Jesus first oh
my gosh my parents are going to really
be bummed